[Music]
on this friday night
new scrutiny hits the greatest outdoor
show on earth
the calgary stampede returns in the time
of coven
they have a lot of weight on their
shoulders the precautions
and the criticism a global national
reality check
is a third dose of the pfizer biontech
shot necessary
the skepticism and the concerns about
ethics
the first glimpse of a fire-ravaged
village in bc
i told him to look forward because
that's all we can do
as the investigation into the cause
ramps up
and houston we have competition space
does belong to us all the race to space
between two
billionaires
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening glad to have
you with us
several signs tonight that life is
returning to normal
our economy is adding more jobs canada's
most populous province is making big
strides in its reopening plan
but perhaps the biggest spark of all the
first major event in canada since the
pandemic began
kicked off today the calgary stampede
and for the next 10 days all eyes are
going to be on the city
as it attempts to do something that
hasn't been done in this country
for more than 16 months there are big
risks being first
but as heather urex west explains there
is plenty to be learned from
what happens now as well
[Music]
in many ways it was a return of the
familiar
but a closer look and all is not the
same
there were no crowds lining the parade
route for this year's stampede kickoff
many participants wore masks we really
are trying to go above and beyond when
it comes
to ensuring a safe experience for
everybody who's participating
the stampede says it's allowed for more
spacing this year
staff are required to wear masks and
anyone who goes into the famous
nashville north dance tent
will have to either take a rapid covet
test or provide
proof of at least a single dose of
vaccine i wouldn't want to be the
stampede at all
i feel they have the tiger by the tail
and
and they're there and they they have a
lot of weight on their shoulders
many in the event planning and tourism
sector are watching stampede closely
as it tests whether events of this size
and scale
can be done safely once again it's
tricky and we see a lot of brands
pulling out of visible participation in
the stampede this year
because of that concern for other
businesses hard hit by the pandemic
having a brand as big a stampede return
is an important milestone too this is
the first
real moment that they're seeing
that they think okay we can come out a
pandemic
and and this is the first real sign of
life but the kovit 19 pandemic is
far from over and there are concerns
that a gathering this size
could foster the spread of the delta
variant particularly among those who
have had just one dose
of vaccine particularly as
people gather off the stampede grounds
as well the wild horse saloon tent will
offer live music and dancing
downtown over the course of stampede
week but unlike nashville north there
will be no rapid test
or proof of vaccine requirement for
entry it's kind of hard to
know what to expect right now we're
prepared we're really excited to be able
to host people again
really excited to be able to have people
enjoy themselves feel safe
have fun get back into it a big
boot-clad step into the unknown
as the stampede tests what's safe and
what people are ready for
after so many months with covet 19.
heather urex west global news calgary
as the calgary stampede gets back in the
saddle so are tens of thousands of
canadians
statistics canada says the economy added
more than 230 000 jobs just last month
the boost is being driven by part-time
positions they rose nearly 264 thousand
bringing it back to near pre-pandemic
levels the bulk of the new jobs are in
the hard-hit
retail and food services sectors the
unemployment rate fell to 7.8 percent in
june that's the lowest
since march of 2020. ontario is going to
move to step three of its roadmap
out of this pandemic next friday that's
five days ahead of schedule the
province's chief public health officer
says
it's possible because vaccinations are
up and cases are down it is an exciting
day for ontario
while we're making great progress
certainly the pandemic is not yet over
but i didn't see any reason to hold us
back given that so many ontarians have
come forward
over 200 000 a day are coming forward
to get immunized some of the big changes
100 people will be allowed to gather
outside and 25
people indoors gyms and other sports
facilities can run at 50 percent
capacity
and indoor dining is back with no limits
pfizer's covet 19 vaccine has become the
workhorse of canada's vaccination drive
but the drug maker is preparing to ask
u.s regulators to authorize
a third covit 19 vaccine the theory is
that it would provide better protection
against the new delta variant
but as michael couture reports there's
concerns the focus right now should be
on increasing
vaccination rates globally
after taking a leading role in
vaccination campaigns
pfizer is now facing criticism it says a
third vaccine shot
may be needed some experts say there's
not enough evidence to back that up
i think that trying to suggest that
there's a need for
vaccines in countries that already have
good access to them is really placing
profits
over the needs of public health
especially when you consider
vaccine coverage across the globe the
darker blue shows countries where more
of the population has at least
one dose of a covid19 vaccine
the world's least vaccinated nations are
also the least
affluent and some feel there's an
ethical concern
about prioritizing third doses in some
countries
while others are still fighting for
their first doses
it's an urgent need to get vaccine
rollout globally
far more efficient and abundant than it
presently is
pfizer says early data from israel shows
a lower efficacy against the delta
variant
but that study isn't peer reviewed in a
rare move
the fda and centers for disease control
and prevention
released a joint statement saying right
now
booster shots are not necessary they're
prepared to approve them
if and when the science demonstrates
they are needed
americans who have been fully vaccinated
do not need a booster shot
at this time a pfizer has not yet
applied for approval of a booster shot
in the u.s or
in canada and while health canada says
it is closely monitoring the possible
need for a booster
bc's top doctor says it may only be
necessary for
immune compromised individuals i think
it's
unlikely from what we're learning that
we'll need to have a booster dose for
everybody in the fall or even into next
year
but that's only from what we're seeing
so far but what is clear to all
is that right now it's more important to
get first doses into arms of
everyone around the world than to
provide boosters
for already protected people michael
couture global news ottawa
today in bc people who fled that deadly
and fast-moving wildfire in litton last
week
got a first look at what's left of their
community residents were taken on a bus
tour off the village to survey the
devastation to homes and businesses
now also today canada's transportation
safety board said it's sending a team of
investigators to litton to examine
whether a freight train
sparked that fire erin mcarthur reports
hard to imagine what it will be like for
people who are seeing for the first time
what's left of their community
their homes it is a mix of emotion
people fearful for what they will find
but determined
that they need to see it firsthand mixed
feelings
it's sad to lose the whole community
or with this
got our house paid off so many people
from the community told me they couldn't
make this trip
it was too much too soon
last wednesday fire consumed the village
of litton
and the surrounding area in just a
matter of minutes the entire
village was on fire and people were
forced to run for their lives
it was just intense intense intense we
only had five minutes to
get out when the fire stuck two people
died in this fire it's hard to believe
it's not more homes destroyed
buildings reduced to chimney stacks and
burnt out vehicles litter the streets
that black cloud almost killed me
i was certain was 100 percent sure
that's it as far as they go
most people have been told they won't be
allowed to return to the area
until sometime in the fall this bus tour
just a glimpse
of what they will need to rebuild right
now
people still in a state of shock
some telling the stories of their
survival for the first time
i could not see two inches in front of
me
blanket couldn't breathe and the thought
in my head
is what a place to die this is behind a
garbage
can friday the federal transportation
minister issued an order
halting all rail traffic and all
construction on the cp and cn mainlines
in the area
people in the community believe that a
passing cn
freight train was the source of this
fire investigators haven't yet made that
link only saying
that it is human caused the
investigation
will be lengthy erin mcarthur global
news
merit bc the assembly of first nations
has elected a new leader
former ontario regional chief roseanne
archibald from the tequatagmo nation has
become the first woman to take on the
role
during a press conference today she said
she's throwing her support behind the
idea of reparations for indigenous
peoples
we have seen the settling of a national
class action where survivors were
compensated
but that's only one piece of reparations
our communities have had long standing
negative impacts as a result of
colonization particularly residential
schools
and we need those reparations to happen
archibald was also asked about an
internal afn report looking into
allegations of harassment and bullying
by her
she said she could not comment on a
confidential report but said she would
support the implementation of a
whistleblower policy
at the afn an investigation
into the assassination of haiti's
president expanse
coming up where the focus is now and
where the suspects are from
plus the potential help canada could
extend to
afghan interpreters
police in haiti have made more arrests
in connection with the assassination of
the country's president
seventeen suspects are now in custody
officers are still searching for eight
others
joanne moyes was killed early wednesday
morning in his own home
as mike armstrong explains the
investigation into his murder
is now taking place in haiti and abroad
it was basically show and tell
patient national police lining up
suspects arrested in the investigation
of the president's assassination
at the other end of the room the weapons
and military gear
that would have been used
the police chief called the men
foreigners who came to the country
to kill the president according to
investigators 28 men were part of the
plot
26 of them were colombia
that country's defense minister is
confirming several of the men
are retired colombian soldiers and is
promising cooperation with the
investigation
the other two men arrested after the
attack are americans of haitian descent
one of them has a tie to canada
james salazz ran a charity out of
florida but according to his online bio
he was
quote chief commander of bodyguards for
the canadian embassy in haiti
in 2010 we hired a lot of people
canada's former ambassador confirmed
salah worked at the embassy but he says
salaz was hired through a security
agency
and never had any sort of a special
title
i saw his face honestly i don't remember
him
now one of the things that shocked the
former ambassador is how quickly the
suspects were caught they didn't get far
in fact most don't appear to have made
it out of the neighborhood where the
attack took place
the number of people you see well it's
quite professional
but on the other side the way they try
to escape the
the resident of the president it's look
quite amateur in my view
the search for the remaining suspects
continues in fact again in the same area
in case the men are hiding
there is also a push on to elect a new
government to fill the power vacuum
president jovanelle moise's
assassination has opened up
i think it's it's challenging
is the director of elections the only
way for the country to take
the path of progress on security
and economic development it has to be
election
now haiti does not have the death
penalty that said according to pierre
this crime is different this is an
insult to the asian people
he won't say if executions are possible
only that this
is quote a particular situation
mike armstrong global news montreal on
august 31st
american troops pull out of afghanistan
hundreds of interpreters who worked
closely with soldiers
including canadian soldiers will now be
left behind
and now a government source who wants to
remain anonymous says canada
is planning to take in vulnerable afghan
interpreters embassy staff
and their families
the taliban are now in control or are
fighting to control
the majority of afghanistan it has left
interpreters
vulnerable the taliban views them as
traitors
there are reports that since 2016 about
300 interpreters who worked with nato
forces
have been killed canada did have a
program to relocate interpreters and
their families
and about 300 people were brought over
but that program expired
in 2011. and three former task force
commanders from canada's war in
afghanistan have written to the
immigration minister
calling for the restart of that
resettlement program
retired major generals dennis thompson
dean milner and dave frazier say
that up to 115 former translators and
their families
are in danger writing if and when they
are found they will likely be imprisoned
or worse
for their service in support of our
mission
dramatic defeat still ahead at canadians
battle against wimbledon's
defending champion
an emotional ending to a dramatic
wimbledon run one of canada's rising
tennis stars dennis shapovalov lost
today
in straight sets to the world number one
novak djokovic
but the 22 year old didn't go down easy
fighting
right until the end and it was a
nail-biter as crystal gomezing reports
the crowd
really wanted the canadian to win
energetic
powerful intriguing positive comments
flowed from wimbledon commentators
fans at the prestigious event were
equally enamored with dennis shapovalov
he's got all the shots doesn't he he's
just exciting to watch
yeah we've had like the golden
generation of tennis and so i think
everyone's looking for what's next
this was shapovalov's first grand slam
semi-final appearance
the 41st for novak djokovic
they were nail-biting moments and the
young canadian
made him work but in the end it was
djokovic who prevailed
he won in two hours and 44 minutes
in straight sets i i would like to give
him
a big round of applause for
everything that he has done
today and uh and also this uh this few
weeks
uh this has been his first semi-finals
of a grand slam and
you could see that he was emotional and
you know we're going to see a lot of him
in the future
definitely he's a great player high
praise for the 22 year old canadian
emotional at the end of his best ever
grand slam run
admittedly a number of tennis fans say
they didn't know a lot about the young
canadian
but he has their attention now they're
not only impressed with his style of
play
but his personality i think it's really
cool
young players and coaches see him as the
next big name in tennis and that is a
huge win for the canadian game
i don't see any reason why dennis can't
take over and maybe go to number one
even today with with novak that first
set dennis was pretty much in control of
it
djokovic now heads to the final on
sunday in what he hopes will be his
sixth wimbledon title as for shapovalov
the 22 year old still has lots of time
to try again
crystal gomansing global news london
billionaires blast off next the ego's
fueling
two rockets in a space race
maria m-u-r-r-a-y-a
that is correct
oh that twirl is everything that's 14
year old zaila avant-garde winning the
scripps national spelling bee
the winning word maria it's a genus of
tropical asiatic and australian trees in
case you're wondering
zaila is the first african-american
winner and the second black champion in
the competition's 96-year history
but get this she's also a keen
basketball player who holds
three guinness world records for
dribbling
multiple balls simultaneously
two billionaires want to go above and
beyond world records
both men will be blasting off into space
this month
on different rockets of course you'd
think the richest people in the world
would be able to rise above petty
rivalries but that
doesn't seem to be the case in this
billionaire space race
here's mike trolley
[Applause]
when amazon founder jeff bezos announced
he'd be going to space on july 20th
there was really only one thing that
could spoil his party
astronaut 01 richard branson
ah billionaires and their rockets virgin
galactic founder richard branson has
said there's no rivalry with bezos
yet branson will enjoy this view nine
days earlier
the seven-year-old branson kept his
intention to fly to space secret
until recently bezos has been more
upfront choosing to fly in the 52nd
anniversary of the moon landing before
auctioning off one of the seats on his
flight
sold 28 million dollars 82 year old
wally funk won't have to pay a thing
as part of nasa's mercury program in the
60s
she had the right stuff but the wrong
parts only men were deemed capable of
being astronauts back then
we're going to fly you up into space on
the very first flight
that's your but it's not exactly the
first flight anymore
thanks to branson although bezos can
bicker about what exactly defines
space his blue origin team's new shepard
rocket will rise above the 100 kilometer
imaginary space boundary known as the
carmen line
with four minutes of weightlessness
while virgin's unity spacecraft will
hover a little lower at 90 kilometers
with six minutes of weightlessness
passengers in both
have a relatively luxurious cabin they
get phenomenal views i mean 90 100 km
doesn't matter the view up there will be
pretty well identical and quite
spectacular
at an estimated 250 000 a ticket
it's splitting hairs or cryptocurrencies
although you have to admire how branson
the consummate marketer
makes it all seem so attainable because
space
does belong to us all maybe one day but
in the formidable frontier of space
tourism
it's billionaires first mike drolite
global news toronto
maybe one day for the rest of us that's
global national for this friday
i'm farah nasser thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
in honor of nunavut day today's your
canada is arctic bay it's captured by an
inuit photographer the nunavut land
claims agreement
act went into effect on july 9th of 1993
paving the way for nineveh to officially
become a territory
six years later robin gill will be with
you on the anchor desk over the weekend
until next time take care of yourselves
and each other